orders have already backed up by the
time head chef Victor steps in to help
with the cooking there's something quite
unique about seeing a father
although dishes are now getting out
there's a problem you're not thinking
don't taste anything
we're normal for the way they work as a
Shirley's picture but the dome lies down
side to cook and also Victor's cook as
well now so you got same dish be killed
by three different individuals so that's
how things started going consistent I
can't believe that Charlie and Victor
are letting down their delicious and
unique ingredients through lack of
seasoning
two different tables once ever enjoyed
the stock sever one elbow we're a little
bit bland so just make sure if someone's
gonna cook it they're gonna taste it as
well if it needs a touch more soul
okay Charlie thank you it's not just the
scallops they're also under seasoning
their most expensive dish three plates
of a 30-pound ahead Dover sole have been
sent back do me a favor do me another
Dover sole solid cylinder season there
definitely needs more salt
and being of service I mentioned that
there was soul yeah fish tastes
delicious but it's underseasoned and
three times tonight he has come back
glands got to do it justice Charlie's
hampered we do the sole it's an
expensive dish to get wrong so many
times
when they hit their stride you and use
food is extraordinary
now that you family need to hear what I
thought up tonight's service this is a
first for me I've never come across a
Chinese restaurant that has such unique
ingredients and so if you are going to
hell him back to sauces ingredients
shout about it I could cry on the back
of the Dover sole because I said to you
when you cooked it for me and earlier it
needed more seasoning and it came back
three times tonight taste it do it just
this yeah you're the chef and your
father's a sous chef and tonight it
looked like you were the apprentice and
your father was the chef and grab the
reins and let him sit behind you well
done thank you
I slowed down if they'd homed in on
those small little details with the
final seasoning across those dishes and
you've got something pretty phenomenal